hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american drama thriller film
called the thinning
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
it is 20 39 and the earth has become
overpopulated
the human race is on the verge of dying
the united nations declares that all
nations must annually cut their
populations by 5
following those orders the united states
implements a rule called the thinning
in the thinning the students must attend
a standardized test every year
in the test whoever fails is executed by
injecting them with a drug
the movie starts as layna michaels is
tutoring a high school kid named simon
simon seems to have a hard time solving
the equations so he asks lena for
something
she takes out a box of lenses and hands
it to him as soon as simon wears them he
is able to solve all the math problems
elsewhere we are introduced to edward
blake redding
the son of texas governor dean redding
he sneaks out of his house at night and
meets his girlfriend
ellie harper in his car blake starts
talking about the test they have the
next day
ellie is very nervous about it but blake
assures her that she will pass
just then blake's father's guard finds
them and brings blake back to dean's
office
dean is disappointed in blake for
sneaking out the night before such an
important test
he thinks that ellie is a distraction
for blake
the following day it is the day of the
test many students lined up outside the
school
they have to go through an intense
security check before entering
blake asks lana for one of her study
lenses but she is out of them
laina and her friend kellen woods stand
in the line to get inside
one of the students had cheats written
in his arms when he is caught he tries
to run away
the guards capture him no one has ever
been able to escape the exams or cheat
on it
inside the school blake and ellie hug
for the last time before entering the
exam hall
and soon the exam starts they have two
hours to complete the test
everyone start solving the problems on
their tablets lena solves all of them
without any problem and is the first to
complete it
her friend kellen seems to be struggling
when the exam is
over they immediately get the results
the teacher in the class is calling
several names who fail the exam
students are anxious hoping this will be
over soon
those who fail are taken by the guards
they cry
resist the guards and some even try to
run away
the guard would beat up those students
who resist luckily
lena kellen and blake pass however
at the last moment blake's girlfriend
ellie is called by the teacher so the
guards take her away
he quickly calls his father and asks him
to help ellie
however his father doesn't agree saying
that the law is the same for everyone
frustrated he runs to save her himself
he attacks the guards and asks ellie to
run away
but to no avail no one would be able to
escape
blake keeps trying to help ellie but
there is nothing else he could do
it is now a year later and 24 hours
before the thinning test starts
it is lena's little sister corrin's very
first thinning test
the doorbell rings it is lana's teacher
ms birch
who has been taking care of lena and
corinne like her own children since
their mother's death
she tries to calm layna down because
tomorrow is karen's first test and laina
worries about her sister
but she assures them that everything
will be fine meanwhile blake records a
video in his room
he intends to write all wrong answers in
the test to teach his father a lesson
cut to the day of the test lena drops
her into her kindergarten
in corinth's class they are presented
with a video animation
showing the current state of the earth
so all nations must annually cut their
populations by 5
some countries implemented rules like
allowing couples to have only one child
while others executed the older
generation in america
however the government decided to keep
only the smartest ones and execute the
others
these children are no exception the
children's test then starts
their teacher is saddened because some
of the children are going to be executed
thankfully
corrine passes the test lana and kellen
enter the school for their test as well
the test starts and finishes in no time
meanwhile
governor dean finds blake's recording
and is agitated
he calls the test manager mason king and
orders him to pass blake regardless of
his score
mason switches his score with lena
making lena fail
the test results are in but to
everyone's surprise lena's name is
called too
she has failed the test ms burch stops
the guard as they take her
claiming that she is her best student
and there must be something wrong with
the system
however the results are final and cannot
be changed
she hands lana a key card so she can
unlock the doors and escape
blake is surprised to not have failed
the students who pass
arrive at a school party to celebrate
their results
elsewhere dean is giving a speech as the
governor to declare his presidency for
the president of the united states
he boasts about their education system
as a result of their system
they manage to be the best in education
among 196 countries
the crime rate is decreasing by 26 blake
listens to his father's speech while at
the party
then sneaks out of it he sneaks into the
hallway and beats one of the guards
he then goes into the control room
meanwhile
layna and the students who have failed
are taken into a room and put against a
wall
they are forced to remove all of their
clothing for decontamination
then lana and the others are taken to a
room where the guards are about to
execute them by lethal injection
suddenly blake cuts the electricity off
making the whole school go dark
taking this chance the students who are
about to be executed
free themselves and try to run away but
none of them succeeds
except for elena she uses the key card
her teacher had given her
and gets out of the room soon after
mason comes to the room and asks for a
head count
they find out that lena is missing and
start looking for her
blake finds lana and helps her fighting
one of the guards
while talking they realize that
something was done to blake and lena's
results
they both enter into a vent and hide
they follow the network cables to go to
the server room where they can look at
the results through the computer
meanwhile the school is still in
complete lockdown due to the power
failure
the news gets outside and is being
broadcasted all over the state
the parents outside are getting
concerned governor dean calls mason to
ask him about the situation
meanwhile the vents below blake breaks
making him fall into the swimming pool
below
lena jumps after him she brings him out
of the water but he is not breathing
laina gives him cpr and somehow manages
to save him
blake and lana change to some clothes
they find in the pool's lockers
they then continue to go through the
vents and reach the server room
but a guard stands in front of the door
moreover lana's key card falls down the
vent in front of the guard
he doesn't notice the card but now she
has to get it back somehow
her plan is to go to the science lab and
join a string with a magnet to fish the
key through the vent
so they head down to the lab to retrieve
the equipment needed
however in the lab they make a slight
noise causing the guard to approach the
lab
they quickly try to escape lana manages
to get back to the vents but blake is
stuck hiding in the lab
lana moves through it to fish the keys
she successfully manages to get it up
halfway
when suddenly a guard catches it but it
turns out that it is blake disguising as
the guard
he had beaten the guard and put his
clothes on shortly
the guard the two of them had attacked
earlier tells mason about them
he reveals that lena had a key card with
her mason gathers all the teachers
together
suspecting that someone has given it to
their students when ms burch is in the
room with other teachers
she flirts with another teacher and
manages to take his key card
mason continues checking the teachers
for their key cards and id cards
birch saves herself by showing them the
card since the
other teacher doesn't have his mason
threatens him to tell them where elena
is
however he insists he doesn't know
anything as mason beats him
laina finally gets to the server room
she opens the computer using the key
card but mason has it protected with a
password
she then texts kellen who is good at
hacking to provide her with the access
after some time cullen receives lana's
text
he helps her to get through mason's
computer lana then searches for her
results and finds out she got 98
but still failed while blake got 15 and
passed
she does more research and finds out
that le2 had gotten 88
and failed while others who had less
marks than her past
lena realizes that the grading system is
rigged and the governor has been failing
whoever he wishes to
lana sends a file with the rigged grades
to kellen but soon
the power is back on and mason sees that
she is in the server room
lena realizes this and runs out however
mason catches her almost immediately
blake on the other hand is still in
disguise
he is with the students who have failed
he orders the guard to take them to the
recreational hall with the other
students
but the guard refuses so they get into a
fight the guards restrain him
and find out his identity just then
kellan receives lana's message and is
surprised to see the rigged results
kellen is friends with a news anchor so
he quickly emails it to the news channel
the reports broadcast the news showing
the receipts of the altercation and the
results
after the photos are leaked the governor
is called by his party head who
threatens to take his presidential
candidacy back
unwilling to let that happen dean
reading throws all the accusations at
mason
and pretends that he is innocent he
tries to prove this
so he has no choice but to execute all
of those who actually failed
including his own son blake at the
school
mason and the guards take lena to the
thinning room to execute her and the
others
blake is there too mason calls dean to
ask him if they should proceed to
execute the students
but dean tells him to stop he wants the
students who have actually failed to be
executed
including his own son the guards free
lana and other students who have
actually passed the test
lena kisses blake but the guards take
him and the rest who have failed
they execute them by injecting them with
a drug as the lockdown ends
lena is reunited with her younger sister
for in and ms birch
cut to a few hours later we see the
bodies of the executed students being
taken underground in an elevator
the students start to move revealing
that the drug they were injected to be a
sleeping drug
they stop when they reach a factory-like
place it is filled with goods being
produced by the tech company assure
global
many people work in the factory just
then blake is surprised to notice that
one of them is actually ellie his
girlfriend
this indicates that the students who are
supposed to be executed are actually
brought underground to work as slaves
for a multi-million company
this was all planned by the government
as a strategy to get free labor
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching